congratulations colonel it's the
secretary colonel Hallam or Colonel
Maura
Colonel you have the thanks of your
whole country especially mine and those
of the President have a seat you've won
a victory that's inspired us all and
made a sure that will ultimately prevail
here in Vietnam my men are the finest
that have ever worn the uniform sir we
know that and they dismembered the enemy
79 dead against 1,800 to 2,000 that's in
the range of 22.8 to 26.2 to 1
sir if you'll permit me when one of my
men that found this in the battlefield
it's gonna be the maze I had it
translated Oh My dear young wife when
the troops come home after the victory
and you do not see me please look at the
proud colors you will see me there and
you will feel warm under the shadow of
the bamboo tree there's from a young NVA
soldier tried to kill me with a bayonet
this man had a life worth living then he
gave it up in a heartbeat dedicated
enemy which made sure a victory even
more commendable indeed we're requesting
forty thousand more troops because of
what your men have proven we think the
president will look favorably on our
request I'll run these little bastards
back home sir they pushed two thousand
men through artillery and napalm and
they came willingly
they charged the muzzles of our rifles
and we took him hand-to-hand any way we
could and we won yeah we slaughtered him
they didn't see it that way
they just retreat and then they come
again
we won't run the little bastards back
home sir
they are home
you